i have it's just straight fire uh we we
might need to split it up into multiple
segments or multiple episodes because i
just got too much fire for one day
myself
[Music]
all right we got a bunch of ideas today
if you like ideas this is this is going
to be one of the podcasts you like i
promise you i didn't bring in any
frameworks or life advice we just went
straight business cool businesses and
ideas you probably never heard of at the
end we just brainstormed uh tv show
ideas uh ideas that could be made into
tv shows so uh i think you'll like this
episode it's a classic it's a it's a
sandwich on classic brainstorm all right
enjoy welcome everybody to the show i
hope we have the new intro music by the
time this airs but we may not i don't
know about you but i've been uh jamming
out to the new intro song
uh pretty excessively and uh it's good
it's good the guy who made it has a
wonderful name
did you say his name young spielberg
that's his name that's a good name i
really like that but young without know
why ung
um all right we have to mention the clip
contest so we're doing this contest i
think if people want to learn about it i
think they go so if they go to
mfnpod.com
they'll see it if you go to
mfnpod.comclips you'll for sure see mfn
pod and you'll see like a link did you
see so these kids it's mostly like
younger like kids that are making videos
where basically the contest by the way
is you chop up these videos so just go
to our youtube page and like download
the videos and chop it up and put it on
tik tok instagram twitter whatever and
if you use a certain hashtag mfn clips
um you're we'll find you and we're going
to get five grand to some of our
favorite clips yeah basically there's
already some amazing things so i saw a
few tick tocks that were already past i
think a hundred thousand views
it's crazy so their tick tocks are their
tick tock account is blowing up just by
taking our content and just chopping it
up and then the guy who did the like
south park looking cartoon thing that
was amazing
amazing this it's a young guy named
corey who's i i followed his account and
he's got like hundreds of thousands of
views on a handful of videos and he
launched the videos and like within a
day or two he had all these views it's
wild and then the guy who does the
cartoon thing i think he's launching a
business and we are his first right
right because i followed his twitter
account he had zero it was like zero
zero yeah
so that's yeah anyways five grand go go
take our content turn it into clips uh
let it go viral and uh yeah everybody
wins
um
all right i've got a few interesting
things you've got many interesting
things you should go first i have it's
just straight fire uh we we might need
to split it up into multiple segments or
multiple episodes because i just got too
much fire for one day
i know what the first one is and i think
we should start with that okay so i
wanted to bring this up there's we had
talked about this in the past but this
is a
story about miss excel
so her name she calls herself miss excel
and i don't know if you've ever seen her
i don't think you're a big tick tock guy
but i am i had seen this person going
viral on tick tock and basically it's a
woman who
puts out like
microsoft excel
tips and tricks like little hacks like
oh
you know how your um things are always
like poorly formatted just put pushed
like you know command g uh when you're
hovering over the column and look it
auto formats everything perfectly or
like do you know what a vlookup is you
do this this and this and boom you can
find anything so she basically puts out
these little clips on tiktok but it's
not just the content like the way she
does it it's like
what works on tick tock it's like
cute cute girls dancing humor like these
are the things that like work on tick
tock
and so she does that she's like she'll
put a song like that's like a trending
song on tick tock um she'll dress up
she'll be she'll have the screen screen
share behind her and she's kind of
overlaid on top of it and then she's
showing something funny that's like
something that's happening she's
explaining it quickly and in an
entertaining way so
she's uh she's here's her story she's a
consultant um
kind of a boring job she was a
consultant
and she decided you know there's a lot
of consultants and bankers that if you
watch the music cell they won't touch a
mouse
like they just use a keyboard like a
wizard and like they could just do
everything just by hitting like
shortcuts and macros on their on the
keyboard in excel there's actually a lot
of people that could do this
who used to work at bcg basically they
had a mouse with like a wired mouse that
was clearly cut the cord was cut and
they like it was like in a frame on the
wall and they're like that's what you're
gonna do here the mouse that's what this
needs to look like you don't use the
mouse
exactly uh and i don't know how any of
this works but uh i've definitely seen a
bunch of friends who can do this they
it's kind of amazing when they're doing
it so
she basically took that idea and started
turning into interesting clips so she
starts off and she tells a story where
she's like you know um
i wanted to like try making some content
and uh you know tick-tock i felt
embarrassed because like isn't tick-tock
like for kids and like it's just like
the silly thing to do i shouldn't i
shouldn't make a ticket on account i'm a
consultant and then her gut was like you
should do a tick tock and so she listens
to her gut she makes a tick tock and
pretty quickly i think within the first
week or so she goes viral with one or
two clips and she gets over like a
hundred thousand views and she's like
holy [__] this is awesome and so she
does it again and she does it again and
then she starts to she's like buys a
little ring light and gets a green
screen so that it looks a little bit
better and she does it again she gets a
video that gets a million views and it's
like wow this is amazing and so she
starts branding herself amazing branding
by the way miss excel like she is the
one she is the excel woman and um
and so i thought that was great and so
she she starts doing this
and she's getting popular but she's not
making any money and uh she reaches or
who what happened morning brew reaches
out they're gonna do a future story on
her and they're like oh we want to
feature you and at the same time a
business coach reached out to her and
was like hey i saw you have this like
really great following i think your your
content is super unique
um
you know and she was like yeah it's
great i'm going to be featured on
morning brew they're like awesome like
what do you have to sell she's like i
don't sell anything it's all free
content and they're like if you're going
to get featured you should have
something to sell and she's like okay
challenge accepted you're right
i'm going to make a course and so she
decides to make a course
she's never done it before and i think
she had like something like two weeks or
something to like pull this whole thing
off and she rushes to do it now let's
fast forward to today
she
is making courses and she is making
six figures a month off this thing so
she's making single digit millions a
year she has a few days
of the year where she's made six feet
over a hundred thousand dollars on a day
in course sales that's kind of like her
black friday um or black friday special
or whatever where she where she sold her
course and so she's doing
millions of dollars a year and she's
working towards million a million dollar
month that's like her goal i want to hit
a million dollars a month as miss excel
and she is like microsoft loves her
they're like pumping her up um you know
she's featured in business insider she's
featured in like buzzfeed she's featured
in a whole bunch of places because this
great story she's featured on this
podcast right now and so she is doing
amazing what i love about this is she
quits her job as a consultant she now
works 15 hours a week unless she's
making a course like but just like a
normal thing she's doing 50 hours a week
she has one employee which is an
overseas virtual assistant
her cost structure is that overseas
virtual assistant which i'm guessing is
making something like six to ten dollars
an hour so you know probably paying them
like 500 a month ballpark
plus uh she pays 97 for thinkific which
is the course platform and she pays a
video editor to um to edit the videos
for the course so like all in all her
expenses are probably like sub fifteen
hundred dollars maybe some two thousand
dollars at the time and um she's making
six figures a month so she's profiting
um you know at least a hundred thousand
dollars a month uh doing this thing and
um there was a whole bunch of like
different little nuggets in there that i
liked but that's the the overall story
quick quick reaction to that
amazing i don't think it's gonna
maybe it will last maybe that was that
was my initial instinct i was like
awesome run but like you know who knows
if this is here two years from now
and then i changed my mind when i kind
of read her read a little bit more about
her here's what i liked okay so we had
talked about excel
way back maybe a year ago when i when we
were talking about i was going to create
a course and we had done a deep dive of
what are the best courses it's always
excel microsoft excel is always on the
top if you go to teachables top courses
udemy's top courses learning to master
excel is always in the top like 10
earning courses and you think it's hard
to be the one but it's a topic people
will pay for anker from teachable he's
got a he's a good twitter follow he uh
tweets out some of the biggest earners
he won't explicitly say who they are but
he'll say one earner we just paid their
you know they just crossed 20 million in
in revenue or in like earnings and then
he'll also say like the top course is
this excel thing so you can kind of like
triangulate it exactly and on udemy i
think i was able to do this as well i
was able to search and sort for the top
best-selling courses and excel was in
the top as well that's amazing
and so i think excel has real demand
then the question is who's gonna be the
best brand in the excel space
and
she's the horse i would pick so um why
do i think that first is her content is
fundamentally better she took the most
um she has the best type of funnel so
what's her top of funnel strategy it's
highly exciting quick hitting snack
sized tick-tock videos tick-tock itself
is like the crack cocaine of content
right like 10 seconds video um with
music overlaid that is crack cocaine for
content and she's using that for excel
when all the other excel creators are
like bloggers and [__] like that it's
like a stale old thing
then her brand and her personality miss
excel
good-looking woman who understands how
to do content and um and she i know she
understands the content she says she's a
little bit when i was researching her
she
is really into some of the [__] i'm into
that's really like kind of like off the
beaten path so she was like yeah she's
like most people when they think of
content strategy like especially for for
this space b2b type of content she's
like it's always like strategic
intellectual trying to figure it out she
goes
i spend most of my time
just getting into a certain state of
mind i just she's like i just get into a
she she goes this is her exact quote she
goes the way i run my structure for my
business is through energetics most
people don't even know what the [__]
that means she goes i get my energy to a
place where my presence is truly
magnetic i get a vision of what's going
to go viral then i run to my computer
and i create that and sure enough it
goes viral she goes because most content
people people don't understand content
is just energy transmission yeah i'm
having a great time i'm excited about
this topic and so i'm going to push that
through the phone into you and sure
enough you're going to learn something
but you're also going to smile while
you're watching my [__] you're also
going to laugh while you're watching my
thing and nobody else is doing that and
i've read that and i go she gets it she
gets like one of the most important
things about business and life which is
it's like maybe able to manage your own
energy but the second part is she gets
the content strategy in a way that i
don't think anybody else is going to
really get in this in this space the
second thing is
go ahead go ahead she now has scales so
at first i was like okay but she's just
like an individual creator on tick-tock
and like who knows maybe tick-tock
algorithm changes no so here's what
she's doing she basically is like i'm
gonna scale in two ways first she's
expanding into the whole microsoft suite
so it's not just excel she's doing
powerpoint and word and outlook and like
everything that like you know a billion
people on earth have to use
professionally and so and microsoft is
helping her and every time they're
releasing a new thing she's getting
first look at it and she gets to come
out right away with the content that's
going to highlight this new function or
this new feature that you get to be able
to use
so
that expansion gives it more legs than
just excel the second thing is she now
hired a performance marketing agency and
she's like yeah get my brand to grow and
she's like the beautiful thing is i
don't sell my course i just put one my
most viral thing and i put ad spend
behind it and people love it like they
love that content and so they like it
they comment on it so facebook's
algorithm promotes it and so i was like
oh that's kind of an unstoppable like
flywheel she's going to keep creating
this like juicy
like quick life hack type content
um then she's promoting it uh that's
already inherently viral then she's
putting a paid ad spent behind it she's
growing her following on instagram now
plus tic toc plus youtube plus all these
different places um and she's like oh
yeah reels came out so then i just like
jumped on reels and i became like one of
the most viral reels creators on
instagram
and um so i'm like okay now she's
diversifying the audience and she's got
the courses behind it and she's going
into more more parts of the suite i like
that formula i was wrong she's gonna
she's gonna crush it i think she's gonna
get to my bold prediction
she's gonna get to a hundred million
dollars in sales and that sounds
outrageous i was about to say 100
million i think she could i think you
could do i think 100 million a year or
lifetime a year
uh yeah i actually agree with you i
think that's bold i think likely
she'll get to like 25 million dollars a
year in revenue and could probably
actually do that for
many years right
uh yeah i think it's crazy um so i loved
i loved her thing there was also these
other little nuggets so she basically
she's working 15 hours a week so then
she's like oh cool quit my job i'm going
to be a digital nomad something you kind
of did this last year she's like every
month me and my boyfriend we just moved
to a different state we just want to
experience it so they'll just move to a
different state in america and just like
hang out there for the month and then
they hop around and uh
the other thing that she's the other
nuggets i liked was she does these like
webinars because she understands there's
like a top of funnel
so top of funnel if you don't know is
basically like how you get new customers
to even like get in touch with you get
in get into your cases it's just going
viral on tick tock going viral on tick
doc or instagram or youtube great then
she has the middle of funnel which is
where a lot of people fall out which is
okay you've touched base with me once
you're not ready to buy something just
yet but how do i actually get you to
participate in a deeper way to invest in
a deeper way
and for her she runs these webinars and
she calls them high energy excel parties
and so she she invites people to these
and what happens is it's of course it's
like
someone from bcg and then they go and
they're like oh this is amazing then
they're like hey we'd like to buy like
1500 seats for our for your course for
our company you know like hey i work for
target uh corporate training and uh yeah
we have 25 000 employees that we think
would be benefit from this how do could
you create something custom for us and
it's gonna be like yeah here's the same
thing but now i say the word target at
the beginning and i charge you you know
five million dollars for i have a buddy
who's doing this which basically is like
his top uh he he does top of funnel
newsletters
then he does these like webinars and
workshops
and podcasts that go deeper and at the
bottom is somebody from you know procter
gamble will reach out and just be like
hey cool like
yeah we got 50 000 global employees uh
we would love to have you come speak at
our headquarters once a month and like
you know we'll pay you um based like a
hundred thousand dollar retainer per
month how's that and he's like whoa okay
that's like way easier than like what's
he teach
so he teaches basically i don't want to
give away too much because i can't say
the numbers then but he teaches like a
version of um
are you familiar with that so he's like
kind of one of the thought leaders in
growth mindset and so big company like
sports teams uh like have them on
retainer as well as you know big
companies like uh whoever you know
coca-cola or whatever will will pay him
and they they're just like look we think
your stuff is great and we have 50 000
employees uh how do we just like package
this up for all those employees and then
like guess what we want to do this every
year and so that turned out to be a very
big business for him and he's just
trying to figure out like what do you
charge a company like this and he'll
just name a number
and uh you know sure enough they'll pay
and he's like oh man maybe i should have
set a higher number i thought that was a
crazy high number but i guess for them
it's like they didn't even blink they
just like said yes so [__] did you see
uh this weekend the world excel
financial modeling championships
happened
no but that is amazing i love that it
went viral uh ben look this up it's like
look up like financial modeling world
championship dude why did i think of
that idea that's such a me idea to think
of it went viral and there was like and
you see these guys it's like all you
know no disrespect it's all nerds doing
it obviously and
you see pictures of them and you see
memes like this is what peak male
performance looks like
and uh okay what what do they actually
do what is the competition so they're
all like you can uh it was they did it
like twitch so like you could like uh
they were streaming their screens and
they were asked to do certain things and
then they had to like in real time like
make this model
and i don't actually know how they
judged it i didn't pay attention i just
paid attention to the memes i think seth
smith tweeted something funny like this
is a gift from god like she showed a
picture of them on there it's amazing it
was hilarious and uh all my indian
friends were sharing it this weekend and
like making indian jokes and it was
awesome it was so funny
but
who who owns that
didn't you see
it's probably like you know deloitte
but anyway so that was amazing this
that's awesome i love
miss excel when this article on the
verge i think it was went live i had so
many people dm me and say you guys got
to cover this so i was going to do it
and so i'm happy you did
baller i think that um i've talked to a
couple friends that have course
businesses and
my friend neville my best friend neville
he had a course called copywriting
course it honestly changed my life and
he made this one course
like
12 years ago maybe
and it's been paying his bills every
single year since then he and he does
other stuff i took it as well he like
updates it and now he has like a
membership thing but
this one thing that he filmed years ago
it's like
it's that's been his career
by the way in terms of transferring
energy uh neville is exactly like that
if you watch in the course he does he's
like like most courses are like here's
an hour-long session about x his is like
it's almost like a blog post and it's
like one minute where he's teaching one
concept and he'll like the camera will
be on and then he'll pop out from under
the table he'll be like yo and then
he'll like say the thing and then the
next one he's got a guitar in his hand
he's like he's like if i'm writing an
email
and i want to get a reply and he's like
singing a song and he's like he he makes
it entertaining and you could just
there's something that makes you smile
and it keeps you engaged it keeps you
involved with it and um you know people
will forget the content but they won't
forget how they felt taking your course
and so they'll still recommend it and
refer it and and be happy with their
purchase can i i'm going to tell you
about uh one or two really quick things
and i think we should spend most the
episode on your stuff because it's
actually pretty good this adventure book
thing looks amazing uh one very quick
thing monthly.com
uh do you know what that is
yeah you see they
explain it so it's just like cause i
think it's pretty under the radar it's
pretty much the exact same thing as
masterclass but only for creators it's
kind of cool i just signed up for my
first one casey neistat which one is
launching a youtubing and storytelling
class
do you see it amazing yeah so i signed
up for it so that's like a cool find so
it's dude how is he not at the [__]
top of the screen right now he's like
just in the middle of this long list
what are they doing it's monthly you
know founders of monthly i think i've
talked to them before they were they
were cool uh they were like
they were cool and they knew they were
cool
i was like hey this is awesome they're
like yeah it's awesome i was like i'd
love to invest yeah a lot of people want
to invest that's right i i appreciate
that so i do respect i just signed up
for that i'm so excited to to do it like
i bought it full price and everything
i'm pumped uh the second thing
another cool product that i've been
fooling around with
well we'll do actually three the second
one is dscript have you seen dscript
yeah we've talked about it so dscript is
kind of like um
editing software
for like you you record something audio
or video and then it like transcribes it
automatically and then if you if you
delete a piece of text from the
transcription it deletes that part of
the video which is like magic amazing
i've been playing with this for my
youtube stuff what do you do with it all
right so you film a video let's say i
film a 10 minute video it uploads the
video and automatically transcribes it
and so i edit the video by editing the
transcription like a google doc
and so i could copy and paste and move
stuff around and that edits the video
it's amazing it's it's almost
transformative because it change when i
think about what i'm going to film i
think about like the the narrative like
a story is just a long narrative and
it's harder to think in video clips it's
much easier to think in transcend in
text
it's super cool and so i actually think
this company they raised money recently
at a 200 million valuation i actually
think this is a company that's going to
be significantly larger than it is now
and well like it's going to be pretty
epic the guy who started it also started
a groupon
yeah it wasn't andrew mason mason
uh he's dope also the best part about
andrew mason that i respect is he he
starts groupon groupon goes on this
crazy run where it's like at that point
in time it was like the hottest startup
in the world copied by like every
[__] you know every joe schmo was
copying groupon
groupon like raises all this money it
ends up going public then it kind of
like
you know then the world turns against
groupon it's like this is not not a good
business it's not going to work people
are pulling out it's it's still i think
like a billion dollar company but like
you know it lost its its shine and he
was in chicago i think
and then he quits or whatever he gets
fired i think he
he got fired i think he wrote something
really hilarious let me write something
really funny all the way out he wrote
like an email he's gonna pull that up he
goes today
i'm paraphrasing he's like today's my
last day i've been fired you probably
know why
like
yeah you know the video i've made making
fun of that ceo who botched the
the the layoffs this was the opposite
this is the ceo who like who got it who
gets it um and so he yeah he wrote this
like letter i was fired today then he
takes a year off and he creates an album
a music album like a rap album of him
just and he's not good but it's
hilarious we should pull up one of the
one of the the videos of his uh his like
rap album or whatever yeah and um he
releases that and then he like came back
with dscript and it started off as this
like walking tour thing which was
amazing by the way the walking tours
were amazing i bought a lot of them it
was really cool but like not that good
of a business because i mean i was a
super fan but like most people you're
never gonna do this and if you do you're
gonna do one in your life
uh but yeah exactly like that by the way
what a great lesson the walking tour was
like uh what people should do and like
makes them like be be more active and
like learn things in the world and then
d script is like hey it's like products
that make you make it easier to be
lazier it's like hey you know editing
video is hard let's make it easier for
you so dscript i've been playing with it
i think it's called dscript i've been
calling it descript unless it's descript
so sorry uh awesome under the radar cool
and then the last thing i'm going to
tell you about that's kind of
interesting so story worth so sean or
ben go to storyworth.com this is a crazy
fascinating thing very simple product i
actually knew the guy nick
he started it i shared an office with
him and he's still i believe the only
employee
and it's kind of cool it's very simple
when i logged in or when i used it years
ago all it was is you pay like 100 a
year or 200 a year and it sends emails
to family members that you sign up and
it asks them about certain memories and
ask them so much over the course of a
year that at the end of the year if a
lot of your family members have answered
some of your prompts you now have a book
describing their childhood so it'll be
my i sent it to my aunt debbie and she
was like
a question i i don't remember all the
questions but it was something like
what's the best memory of your father
before you were 10 and she was like you
know on halloween we did this thing and
and it's like oh my gosh i'm learning
about my family and at the end i printed
out this book super fascinating and it's
super fascinating um because
it's a one-person business it's just him
and right and it's really simple it's
very easy and i love that ancestry stuff
so much like i'm a big fan of that um
anyway that's why yeah that's cool
that's really cool i um i've never used
something like this so isn't it kind of
a lot of work for the other person to
like write an answer like i feel like
people don't like to do stuff like that
yeah but if you get what you get one a
week and you spend like 10 minutes of
journaling yeah it's work but i like
told my aunt i was like hey this is
important to me and she after a while
she was like oh i kind of like doing
this i'm remembering a bunch of stuff
it's a lot of work we had done a version
of this or there's a version of this
that's like
i think a little easier which was um i
don't know if you remember i had when i
i had my mom over uh she was doing a
podcast with her and i recorded a
podcast with her and the podcast was so
much easier because really all they had
to commit to was like one time hey let's
sit down and talk and you get this
hour-long thing with their voice and
they don't have to like people get
pretty intimidated having to write
something there's this pressure
internally to like uh
do good writing i think school like
traumatizes the [__] out of people and
um this podcast thing
worked great i did it i had an amazing
podcast with my mom i recommend anybody
you don't need to be a podcaster by the
way like this i don't publish this
anywhere but it's just a memory i'll
always have and it was a conversation
that i wouldn't have otherwise had more
importantly like i don't even know if
i'll ever go back and listen to this
maybe give it to your daughter on that
really horrible day
yeah like you know when she she passes
away like i'll be happy i have this but
more importantly it was like
so much of life is um so surface level
and like we're just talking hey like
we're just talking about me and my life
all the time
b like if i'm talking to her it's about
like what we're doing today or whatever
i realized i knew very very little about
like her and her family and her what
made her her and like her upbringing um
because you know i don't know that was
just [__] in the past and so
um and even she forgot a lot of these
things and in the conversation it all
was coming flooding back to her so i
recommend everybody do that with their
parents uh like just sit them down and
record one hour thing and i can share
like the questions i asked or whatever
but it really doesn't matter to be
honest with you have you done ancestry
or 23andme
i've never done it no
they're awesome so 23andme is awesome
ancestry is i think cooler because i've
spent hours on it like building up my
family tree 23andme i've thought about
getting it for i have it and i've
thought about buying it this christmas
for my family members the reason i'm not
i may not do it have you heard of this
thing called ged match
no was that oh have you heard of the
golden state killer
no okay so
in the 1970s there was that's what they
call you
yeah that was my nickname in high school
golden state killer uh in the in the
1960s 70s and i think 80s there was this
guy who basically like raped like 50
women and then he murdered eventually
like 20 of like he was a serial killer
and uh he got away with it for years no
one knew who it was and patton oswalt's
wife pat oswalt the comedian his wife
who recently died right before she died
published her like master work or life's
work and it was about the golden state
killer and how he's never got been
caught and it renewed interest and then
the fbi got all into it because all the
press and they eventually used this
website called ge it's public
it's like a anyone can use it it's like
an open source website and it analyzes
all of the uh
information from 23andme ancestry and
like all that stuff all the
database stuff and they found they put
his dna the golden state killer's dna
which they had into this ged match thing
and they realized that the daughter of
the killer or like they're like well
this is so aligned it must be like the
daughter or the granddaughter of the
killer recently signed up for 23 and me
and so they stake out this guy's house
they dig through his garbage they find
they go boom got him and that's how they
arrest him and they arrested him when he
was like 80 and died
and if you google golden state killer
you'll see like these pictures of this
old man and they got him because he got
away with it for so long but eventually
they brought him to justice and
now
they've caught many dozens maybe even
hundreds of killers or rapists this way
which is good
but
it's kind of scary and so you could so i
was gonna say so you're you're worried
about this why why is this working
because it's being used for good grandpa
and trouble it's being used for good now
but
like
you could see like do i want to be in
the state do i want to be in this
database and so this is one thing i'm a
bit worried about so you can go to ged
match and you can upload your results
and it can tell you all types of stuff
about your results you can see uh a lot
of interesting stuff and you could like
if you can somehow get the dna from an
fbi case which i believe in some cases
you can you can like upload it and
there's like
thousands of like these internet
detectives using this database to solve
crimes it's kind of fascinating it's
kind of interesting and it's definitely
a little scary
wow is there like a subreddit for these
uh you know like sort of like public
crime solvers yes there is and it's very
very interesting and most of the time
they're wrong so like if you remember
when the boston like the boston uh
marathon bombing they like named like
these like three guys and they they kind
of [__] with these guys lives they
they didn't end up doing it but everyone
was certain on that subreddit and
they're uploading pictures and they go
this guy works at this place it wasn't
them they were wrong no one guessed it
that it was the two actual guys but this
is a little bit different because it's
dna but dna isn't perfect so it's like
there's a it'll say like there's a um
this person is five percent related to
this person so it's like all right let's
see what that is that could be like a
distant cousin until you like track your
way down to that and you build these
family trees to figure out oh you know
it's kind of weird that like this
matches this person and they're they
also lived in the same area and so it's
not perfect but it's like pretty good so
anyway i thought that's why i may not
get 23 in me
[Laughter]
yeah i also know people who have gotten
it and realized like their dad is not
their real dad um and i think that that
happened to a family member i think
that's a you know
uh you know side effect to be aware of
sometimes ignorance is blind family
member of mine
a family member of mine found out that
their parent had a
their parent cheated on the spouse and
had a a a kid
and so they logged on and they go oh man
i've got a second brother or whatever
you know like a step brother or a half
brother
and uh it changes [__] yeah i was gonna
say without getting too personal that
that uh that has like that they went
public with it or they just kind of kept
that information to themselves no no no
they did not go public with it but it
like was very it was i don't know they
haven't talked about it with me too much
but it was it seems like it was like uh
somewhat earth shattering yeah there's a
there's a thing that i've heard that
goes on which is um people who
uh
people who use sperm banks so like a
sperm donor
um will take the test
sorry people who didn't realize
that their parent had used a sperm donor
or whatever they will get the sequencing
done or whatever and they'll find out
like oh my god i have 42 like half
brothers or sisters out there it's like
oh yeah this was a person who
um
you know this is a person who donated a
bunch and then so yeah you actually do
genetically share with all these
different people
um like wow that's really crazy so
there's all kinds of like interesting
stuff and i think 23andme
their business model is to sell your
data right like i think that is the core
business models they sell pharmaceutical
companies
for um
you know like the research or whatever
like i don't know if it's [__] up or
if it's like this is for the good of
science but i don't think you
really know or opt-in it's not clear
that hey like it's not clear yeah it's
probably it's definitely the terms you
know but nobody's reading the terms and
so that's the problem it's like
it's like a benevolent dictator it's
like it's cool when they're making the
trains run on time it's not cool when
they start killing people
you know what i mean
yeah it's like it's good when it's good
and then but it could go bad really
easily
yeah uh all right what else we got do
adventure book
all right so this is another so to me
the miss excel thing was one this other
thing i think is really interesting so
the adventure book let me tell you about
this story have you heard do you know
what this is this product the adventure
book
i have no idea what it is ben have you
ever heard of this thing
okay all right so you guys are also not
on tick tock enough this is like the
number one ad on tick tock that i see uh
i don't know if i'm just in their market
or they just run a [__] ton of ads but
i've been seeing it for like a year so
basically it's a
it's kind of it's a book you buy
and it's like a high quality big book
and what it is is like there's a bunch
of imagine like a scratch off like a
lottery so there's a bunch of things you
can a bunch of adventures that you could
scratch off so you open the book to a
random adventure you scratch it off and
it reveals a thing you're gonna go do
like it might be um
uh like
i don't know i've never bought the book
so like you know bad example but like
you know you're gonna go into a store
today and you give out ten compliments
to people in the store or uh you're
gonna go streaking around your
neighborhood or whatever like an
adventure a thing you can go do
and um
so this idea and and and they pair with
it like a camera so you you're supposed
to take a polaroid of you doing it so it
becomes a scrapbook so on one side it
triggers you to go do something that
you've never done or that's like you
know get you out of your comfort zone uh
and then it gives you the ability to
capture it and paste you glue the photo
in and it becomes this memory book of
all your adventures like cool kind of
novel idea so i had seen this and i was
like ah that's a cute idea that's a
novel idea
what i didn't realize is this is a
hundred million dollar business
that was
created in the last like two years so
how do i know this
you know like for the podcast i don't
know if you get these emails but i
definitely do
um there's a bunch of people that have
like booking agents and we get all these
emails which is like hey sean love my
first million um have you thought about
having you know
joe
joe on and you're like
you know it's like oh first
they're complimenting me so i like open
it and i'm like looks like i don't want
to be a member of any club that will
have me
you know so it's like that's how i feel
about the guest thing so normally i
write all these off but this one caught
my eye which was they said would you
like to have brian ellis on he is a high
school dropout now owns a 100 million
dollar business called the adventure
challenge and i was like it's like that
that adventure book thing and it and so
i replied i go 100 million dollars no
way that sounds high
and she goes yeah like it's been
incredible they've grown blah blah blah
and i said
100 i'm just like clarifying like 100
million cumulative revenue annual
revenue what are you saying here
and uh and so she goes yeah like
they'll do 85 million in revenue this
year and they have a few big bigger
partnerships than distribution
partnerships that will get them over 100
um like in the next year and you know so
the business is valued over 100 million
dollars um with 85 million in revenue
and i was like what the [__] and so i go
and i start researching this
and so here's the story
so this guy bryant he's um
i so i couldn't confirm the high school
dropout part i don't know if that was
just like some post-fact [__] like like
to make this sound better but like let's
assume it's true so uh high school
dropout i think his job was he had some
job which was like he was a skyscraper
inspector so he's like you know some low
man in the totem pole doing a job he
didn't love and he's like all right i'm
just doing this for the money
he wanted to make a business like he
just he's like my whole life i just
always been i always have ideas and and
you know i wanted to come create a
product it's like so i'm doing this job
and i had this idea to do um to do this
like adventure box so his original idea
was take a machine uh create a box like
a machine
and you push a button and it's like
like prints out a receipt the receipt is
like the adventure you're gonna go on so
you get like a random adventure that
comes out cool idea right
and um and so that was the original idea
and he's like ah just tells a couple
people about it and they're like oh yeah
that's cool and he's like great but he's
doing his job and he hasn't really you
know figured out exactly how to do it or
whatever um
and he's like he's like okay but he's
he's he everything's like on hold until
he gets fired from his job and he like
uh he he makes a mistake they think he
committed fraud his boss is like no no
this honest mistake but either way he
gets fired he's like all right [__] um
what do i want to do so he decides i
want to go to acting school so he's like
i'm going to go to acting school but i
need to pay for life so he's like i need
to create a side hustle that's going to
make me 2 000 a month that's my goal and
he's like he's like what about that
adventure box challenge thing and he's
like the idea over the course of a few
months had like evolved and he's like
all right what if it was actually like a
book that you could scratch off the
adventure um
and so he tells a couple people about it
and they're like that's actually a
really cool idea you should do it and so
he goes to hobby lobby and he buys some
paper some of the scratch-off material
and he and he's like buys it he goes to
a different store he buys a camera and
he's like starts coming up with this
idea and he basically spent six to eight
months prototyping this idea because
nobody had really done a like kind of
like um an adventure style scratch-off
book before so he's like creating an
actual physical product
and so he's like um he has this idea and
he um he just keeps telling people about
it and so he
um he gets to the point where he's
prototyped the idea several times and
there's videos i found online of like
he's creating a vlog while he's doing
he's like all right it's 11 p.m april
1st uh i just got this really cool
material for the scratch off i really
like this one but i'm having trouble
with the bindings you know and he's like
so maybe i'll try this other thing
tomorrow and then like he has the next
video you know a week later he's like
okay i figured out the bindings part and
now i need to figure out this other
thing i love seeing the the start the
early stages of these ideas
so he creates a kickstarter he's like
i'm going to do a kickstarter it's going
to be great i want to raise ten thousand
dollars for this book
and uh kickstarter goes live he makes
thirteen hundred dollars the first day
and he's like [__] yeah i'm the man he
you know goes to a coffee shop he's
strutting in he's like i made 1300 today
i don't know about you guys i'll take
you know your best give me your finest
coffee
and uh he's like all right we're you
know we're already 13 of the way the
goal let's keep going but day two
day three zero dollars and like the
kickstarter like runs out of steam he's
like [__] i was kind of just banking on
this going viral and now it's not viral
so
what now and so he's like all right
basically he's gonna throw in the towel
he's like for for only seventeen hundred
dollars i can't even get the quality of
book made that i want
uh maybe i'll just quit so he's like i
need to get a job to pay for life um you
know like i'm out of money and so he's
like he's like oh maybe i'll contact my
buddy i don't forget his name but ben my
buddy ben to uh
to get a sales job he has like this
company i can do sales so he calls him
up he gets a sales he's like i want to
do a sales job i want to do it for one
year
and i'm just saving up money so i go
back out there and build a product and
the guy's like all right cool that's
fine like you're upfront about it like
i'm down with that let's do it so he
gets a sales job there and while he's
there he's telling people at work this
idea he can't shut up about the idea
and um
and the guy there was like you know have
you tried ads he's like oh dude nobody
clicks ads like ads like
reds like ads are scams basically like
that's his mentality at the time and the
guy's like no like that's how we grow
our business like you know you should
try so he puts a little money into ads
he's like i don't know if it worked or
not but like you know i got this like
10x roast and the guy's like what
like no way and he's like yeah like
people really like the ad or whatever
and so the guy he partners with his
buddy the guy who hired him and he so
i'm fast forwarding some parts of the
story but basically he ends up leaving
that guy partners with him that guy's
like look we're gonna grow this thing
through ads
and um and they basically run a [__] ton
of tick tock ads facebook ads whatever
and they've grown this thing to now 85
if this is true 85 million dollars in
sales they've sold about 2 million
copies of this book it's like a 40 book
which is like you know something 70
something million dollars in sales if
you do the math
and um
and yeah what an adventure and now they
have like a couple's book so you're like
50 fun adventures to go on with your
date they have a family book here's
something to do with your family a
friend's book and then a by yourself
book and um
yeah it's kind of amazing i am into
these notebooks i told you i used one of
these best self code right yeah but
that's different that doesn't have like
a product it doesn't have to go do
things in the real world
it does it does the the one i use i use
like a relation we use like a marriage
one and so i'm into this this guy's
amazing how old is he uh he seems very
young so i don't know how old he is um
he looks like he might be 25. this is
amazing
max i don't know
i think these box things are cool we
talked about one that was doing like 100
million in revenue and it was um
remember it was that like catch a
catch a criminal box you remember that
oh what was that what is that one that's
a is it a truth it was amazing it was it
was a true crime thing it was thirty
dollars a month and they send you a box
and you solve a crime with your friends
it's so good it was so fun and this is
in that same world i think it's cool to
like
it feels special to me to order
something and to like see a physical
get a physical thing and uh i'm into it
i think this is badass i like so often
true crime won better than this because
that's a repeat that's like a recurring
one
or it'll have more repeat purchase than
this
um it's so fun
and uh i do one i buy this thing called
kiwi for my niece which is like it sends
her like kind of like a science fair
project basically it's like here's a kit
you're going to build a like
a little like mini tractor it's sort of
like legos or whatever but it's not like
one specific thing
or sorry it is one specific thing
um it's like here's you learn about
electricity through this little like box
every month and it's not great but it's
good enough and like she loves it so now
if i cancel i have the guilt of like her
not getting the toy she wants and so i'm
like i'm gonna just keep this 20
subscription forever i i guess
i'm on board with this i think this is
awesome i think
who by the way whoever's making clips
this should be the clip uh that you make
this guy's story's like i was enthralled
this is amazing wow um all right what
else what else you want to do i have uh
keep going okay i have a segment it's
not even a full segment it's just
uh the start of a segment
i think this one might be bad but let's
try it uh i basically pretend i'm drunk
and then this will be like ah that's
pretty good for a drunk guy um
i have a bunch of half-baked tv show
ideas do you even drink i'll drink you
know if the occasion calls for it i'll
drink but not regularly no
um
but i want to pretend i was drunk when i
came up with this list because it's kind
of just like a random ass list of weird
ideas so these are half-baked
tv show ideas okay uh this is for the
you know the producer who listens to the
show the netflix guy who listens to the
show uh
you're welcome in advance i want to get
your reaction to my concepts okay i'm
going to pitch you three ideas uh i
don't know if you have any any tv show
ideas i'm gonna pitch you three
okay okay the first one is called frat
you
um
i love i don't know if you've seen um
the
football one that's on oh my god what's
it called there's like a football one
called uh something on netflix it's like
one of their original shows
that basically follows a a junior
college football team around
and um uh
it's like here's the coach here's the
players and it like picks six players
and it's like you kind of get
emotionally invested in their story
there's a formula one show that's just
like this it's like here's these six
drivers you get invested in there yeah
it's amazing their story there's a
cheerleading version of this that i
watched i think it's called cheer i
don't know what it's called exactly but
it's like
here's this the the best cheer card you
know that that was like you know that
that was like the most popular show and
it's not like something you discovered
i'm i'm a pretty you know a good curator
here so you so i don't know a lot of
people didn't watch the show because
it's like why would i watch a chat i've
heard of this thing called squid games
so i signed up for the service called
netflix that's pretty great uh
all right so this same model
i think it'll be applied to a whole
bunch more topics the one i'm surprised
at is why is there not a reality show
just inside one of the craziest frats in
america
because you know that they would
basically go all out sell out to make
the show entertaining because they want
the fame
well i think it's a faux pas have you
ever talked to like an 18 year old man
they're woke no dude no that's are they
just like the that's like the 18 year
old who's like talking to old people
like us most 18 year olds don't interact
with people like us and they're like
very normal and just trying to have a
good time in college they're not like
are frats are frats popular you think i
would think they were going down dude
like this are super popular because it's
a bubble like when you go to a college
it's like in such a little bubble it's
not really affected by like the way the
world is changing uh you don't have to
you're not you're not you're not
convincing me i understand the value but
i i didn't even i just thought that like
with everything going on that it was
like a faux pas no dude if you go to
arizona state or you go to like you know
wherever you know georgia do you think
they give a [__] about like you know
locism and they're disbanding the frats
hell no they are have you seen the
doubling date well there's these there's
these girls on tick tock that do this
challenge or not this challenge but i
forget what it's called if you're a tic
tac guy you probably know but uh
sarah showed it to me it's these girls
who are like pledging i think is that
what it's called i i wasn't part of that
uh where you
i don't know what you do it's like you
it's like a tryout and they always talk
about what they're wearing
i'm i'm a i'm an old man and i was a
dork i wasn't part of a frat but they
like talk about the clothes that they're
wearing to their their like pledge
ceremony things like that and it's gone
very viral on video uh what's so
noticeable about the watches
i don't know but it's just funny it's
just hilarious because like don't you
know how like in the south and like at
ole miss and stuff like that the the
sororities do these uh like yeah they
all like i went to a southern college
yeah yeah for sure like
like they all like it's all like the
boss girls they all look exactly alike
and they dress exactly alike and that's
like the joke is they like show like
what they're wearing duke you weren't
even allowed to throw a party if you
weren't afraid or sorority like they
literally were like you better join this
[__] or uh you don't get to have a
social life
dude it's weird it's so weird to me
that's so weird also whenever i go to
one of these friends i'm like this is
disgusting i don't want to live with
like a bunch of dudes or alcoholics and
there's like 80 of them in this crappy
house and there's beer [__]
now
how about you when you're like getting
drunk all the time even back then
but even back then i'm like this is bill
i want to get drunk
i just don't want to be around a bunch
of like degenerates all the time oh okay
well you're alone in that i would love
to uh go back and experience college
again i think it was a great time and
living in one of these houses was yes
messy but fun
anyways point is
you go to a party school you go to ole
miss you go to georgia you go to
you know santa barbara or whatever and
it's frat you and you basically just
follow around with a king alpha frat you
go inside the house and you pick the
five characters who are the [__] you
know they got they're gonna have all the
elements of a great tv show they're
gonna have relationship drama they're
gonna have infighting they're gonna have
camaraderie with the boys they're going
to have a hazing and a a pledge process
that's going to be controversial and get
them to do all kinds of outrageous
stunts it's all baked in the show
basically writes that you got to have
like like one guy questioning his
sexuality exactly he comes out he's
another guy he's afraid they're not
going to accept him but they accept him
there's the the person who gets canceled
for doing something racist or sexist or
something like that
it's got all the elements and then you
could just hop from school to school and
the schools would be excited oh [__]
frat u is coming
we gotta represent because you know
georgia looked like they had a good time
so now all of a sudden clemson is like
oh you think georgia was hardcore look
how we party look how we do our thing i
think this is a no-brainer franchise
that somebody needs to create and uh you
could put me down as executive producer
all right next okay
basic to baller okay what is this um
i
recently met somebody i'm gonna do a
separate episode of this but i recently
met somebody who was uh completely
um
like
middle class or a little lower middle
class like didn't have any money
all their all their tastes were that of
a basic person right they
they didn't shop at whole foods they
shopped at kroger right they didn't uh
they didn't eat like fancy stuff they
you know like mcdonald's and stuff like
that they um they didn't drive a fancy
car they drove like a camry and like
okay so that was their like taste buds
so i thought what if you had a show
where you just give a really basic
person
[__] you money and they get to go ball
out and you get to see their reaction
because
already shows where people ball out uh
like like you know whether it's like
kind of like a million dollar listing or
it's like uh selling sunset or it's like
kardashians it's like it's nice to see
the lifestyles of the rich and famous
people like that
but those people also there's that genre
of
lifestyles of the rich and famous from
people who are already rich and famous
and sort of like you know snobby and
materialistic okay that already exists
what about some what if you transformed
somebody you gave them the cinderella
treatment they went from the you know
the bottom to the top suddenly and
they're now just discovering all these
things for the first time
hilarity ensues okay that's my second
let me make it
let me put a twist please i actually
think that you could do this or someone
listening could actually do this
immediately via a youtube series so in
2005 there was a documentary called
reversal of fortune it was on showtime
it was amazing and the question was what
would a homeless person do if they were
given a hundred thousand dollars and so
they found this homeless guy they gave
him a hundred thousand dollars and they
show him going to like a hotel for the
first time and sleeping in a bed for the
first time and he's like i don't like
this and he sleeps on the floor of the
hotel because he's like it's not
comfortable sleeping on this bed and
they give him a hundred thousand dollars
and it ends
not good so he spends all of his money
on women he buys a 35 000 truck and this
is like thirty five thousand of the
hundred grand and basically blows
through all the money and
he does get a job but he like all the
money is gone on basically partying and
uh at the end of the movie he's only got
five grand left and he's sleeping at his
sister's house uh but i actually think
it's not great for him but sounds like
great tv to me
it was great tv i was watching it the
whole time so uh i think what could be
it
what you should do is just get a hundred
thousand dollars and do a youtube series
on this you i think you can make your
money back and add revenue that's that's
the thing
i think i think if you did it with a
homeless person you might get some
blowback now uh so you know yeah not
with the homeless person but like you
know like what would happen if like you
know a
someone who's in need or doesn't have
much is given a given yeah and i think
it kind of needs to be temporary like uh
you know so you know with like pimp my
ride you know exhibit shows up at the
door and then like your life just sort
of changes overnight um or like you know
wife swap or whatever where it's a very
short period it's like a month or
something like that i think you need to
let them ball out and then let them
return back to reality um
and you see that that sort of the yo-yo
of emotions between them okay so that's
my my second one okay third one very
easy show
i just need a show that's background
noise are you a background noise kind of
guy do you just have something on
because it just feels better to have
something on
uh in our when we had a physical office
we had we had white noise machines
throughout the office and i enjoy that
baby's to sleep
it was so you could have like hard like
if you want to have a conversation in a
conference room and for it not to bleed
through the walls right uh and it was
difficult newsletter conversations
yes or like when you have like an open
office plan you put it in like pods of
deaths so then like the people eating
lunch don't bother you uh now i keep the
fan on well you're also like a music
video guy right i remember we were at
your house you were just throwing up
like on apple tv like a bunch of music
videos
i have music videos playing uh
throughout the day yeah okay so that's
the behavior i'm talking about
i think that netflix does not does
anyone else do that you don't do that
you don't have to i don't do that but my
wife she'll always put like friends on
i'm like dude you're watching friends
and she's like no i'm not like i'm not
watching i'm like why do you have it on
can i turn it off no no i like i like
having it on
it's like yeah
she doesn't like if there's like kind of
like an empty home feeling and also it's
this comfort
safety blanket where it's like i already
seen all the episodes and that is why
the office and friends are such valuable
catalogs because people just put them on
and they can only pay
10 or 20 attention to it and 80 could be
on the thing they're trying to do
and they can just glance up and you know
see certain parts but then they just
don't it's a low maintenance show and
when you go on netflix today
so much of it is high maintenance
attention uh it's like oh here's this
intense story about this bank heist and
that's great when you want like a friday
night intense drama
but i think they're underserving the
background noise and i also learned this
at twitch because
when i was at twitch
we looked at some of the data about the
usage data and somebody was pointing out
like oh yeah like
x percent i can't say the exact percent
but like a significant percent
of the viewing time is uh when it's not
the tab that's in the forefront on
people's computer
and i was like oh so we should just like
throw that out right like they're not
even watching they just like
accidentally left it open
and i was like why is this such a high
percentage do we have some bug that like
it stays open in the background in some
weird way they're like no this is
actually the use by like all the
developers what are you talking about
the developers who actually use twitch
all the time they're like this is how i
use twitch all the time like i'm coding
i just have it on in the back i'm just
listening to him like you're listening
to somebody play video games like if
there's one thing weirder than watching
somebody play video games it's listening
to somebody play video games like no i
just like it as like a ongoing
background stream it's kind of my
favorite streamer and i don't really
need to pay attention to it but i'll hop
in if something if i hear something cool
happening i was like holy [__] so
there's this
big genre of background entertainment
that i think you if you specifically
tried to make in make
background entertainment you could
create some really successful franchises
so can i can i can i tell you something
that validates us so you know chive
chive dot com um i think it's just like
a news website or something i don't
really know much about it a little bit
it's like basically bar stool but a
slightly different demographic but
mostly the same
and they created this thing called chive
tv and so what they did was they uh
would in their base in austin they
basically gave a little amazon fire
stick to a bunch of bars in austin and
they said you could have this stick for
free and on this stick is basically
we're gonna put loads and loads of
different clips of basically like
america's funniest home videos basically
guys getting hit in the balls and like
funny bar stuff that you don't actually
need any sound to understand or to get
like pleasure from and so it was like
silly stunts guys jumping off
skyscrapers and like skydiving and stuff
and they eventually spun this off and
they created this business called
atmosphere and this was making tens of
millions of dollars in revenue
pre-pandemic i believe they raised tens
of millions of dollars at like a 200
million valuation and they would give
these
these these
uh fire sticks to like loads of
different people and then eventually you
could just download this app and they
would fulfill the uh put content in the
pipe and then put ads on it and that's
how they made all their money and they
go look advertisers you're reaching all
these bars right yeah yeah that's bars
is a great one right that's like perfect
background background entertainment okay
so those are my three tv show pitch
ideas half-baked ideas uh do you have
any ideas is there a show that you think
could exist or would exist or should
exist i know i'm putting you on the spot
here
no but
so one that has caught my eye youtube uh
on youtube cnbc is doing something that
i think is actually amazing it's called
millennial money stupid name and the
branding is really dumb but what they do
is
no they got the idea is cool though my
friend steve was on it the other day
they convinced these people and they say
like and the titles are like here's how
we live on a million dollars a year in
silicon valley here's how we live on
forty thousand dollars here's how we
live
and i've also seen kevin o'leary reacts
to them have you seen this that's what
they they that's also awesome
i think it's a great series i think
they're missing the mark though but even
though they're missing the mark it's
still quite good and so i've always
thought that uh for
different stuff i was like what you what
you should do is get you could do it one
of two ways
i've always thought what you could do is
you could maybe have a podcast or get
actors and they like i bet you if i send
out a survey
and i've done this before we did this at
the hustle we sent out a survey we
posted on hacker news and we got like
3 000 people to tell us how much money
they have in their checking account how
much they have in investable assets how
much they spend at each month and then
just like a comment box and they like
leave comments and if you search like
the hustle founder bank account like we
we did an article on it and people would
give us all their information and it was
all anonymous though and
and it was pretty great and i always
thought it would be interesting to where
we can do a podcast where i just ask
these people questions and then i'll
hire a voice actor just to read them
right right right i like that i also
really like that survey kind of idea
because the people people are very
willing to share because they've no cost
them it's anonymized it's you know it's
not being
publicly shared that it's their their
information but people really benefit
from
seeing what the aggregate is doing uh so
we talked about this with salaries with
levels.fyi as well as uh somebody heard
the thing for levels and then they made
it for do you know about the story
someone heard our podcast levels they
made it for
doctors doctors and then they got
acquired by levels and so they now work
out oh it got a question they got
acquired they got aqua hired maybe it's
better way to phrase it like those guys
now are like you know like doing their
thing at levels um
he's like dude thanks for like that idea
it led me to like a it got me off the
path i was on i built something cool i
got to learn from that and then i got a
sweet opportunity at levels through that
um
so
but there's another one that's going
viral right now that's like i think a
hundred and seventy five thousand tech
workers have put their stuff into this
spreadsheet
yeah i've seen that what's that called
it's literally just a google sheet it's
like it's broken because it has too many
rows now um like nobody can like use it
they like they're like asking for excel
experts to like help them you know like
format this so that they they don't lose
the data but like people can still put
their stuff in i saw that they're
basically doing it because they want to
end uh like
like maybe if you're a minority or
something at facebook you're like i
don't know if i'm getting [__] here
can everyone please enter their salary
anonymously so i know like is this fair
not fair yeah and that's how it got
started and so people were like rallying
behind it and and it went viral i saw
that that was pretty cool yeah um
all right that's all i got for today i
got a couple other ideas but i'ma save
them
all right i think that was a good one
benjamin what do you uh what do you
think of this one
give it a grade this was an a um
this was an a minus
[Laughter]
okay walk me through that it was an a it
was a it was an a because it was good
top to bottom like all of it was good
and then i decided to add the minus at
the end because it was missing uh like a
hose water sam moment like it didn't
have anything that i was like
rolling on the floor laughing or
anything like that so i docked it to a
minus
dude it's because
my freaking camera's screwing up it it
knocks me off my flow so much i can't
stand it
um
apparently
i did so i
some people say we're funny which shocks
me and uh like the other day
noah was like you have to take notes
about reading a book and i'm like dude i
just read a book about like the navy
seals like am i supposed to take notes
about how like bin laden was shot in the
head
and uh like apparently people wrote in
the comments they like when we say dumb
stuff like that and that shocks me
[Laughter]
when people say they listen i'm like
i'm like really
so i don't know if you're just doing
that thing where it's like fake fake
humble like oh
gosh
i didn't know that guy like because no i
think it's funny like i think it's
funnier you're funny
i think you're funny as a group i would
say we're like mildly funny but i
wouldn't say funny is an attribute that
i would like give
this
show and i think you're way funnier also
i i even texted you this because you
would you had sent me something that was
so funny and i was like dude you're
funny
[Laughter]
no you said a left-handed compliment
you're like i don't think a lot of
people understand this but you're pretty
funny like i made a joke the other day
someone posted a picture with them with
their arm or it's just like a headshot
of them with apollo anton ono the ice
skater and i was like i don't know who
that is it's someone says that's apollo
antonino i'm like oh sorry i didn't
recognize him without a skate song
there's like little comments like that
and no one laughed at it and i was like
guys that's hilarious that was funny
that was funny i should have given you a
laugh because that wasn't that was a
good one um
and uh yeah so i think we're funny you
have a you're blunt which is that's
funny in itself right you just you just
say something
and uh you don't hedge which is like
makes it even funnier because
everybody [__] hedges nowadays so you
don't hedge or apologize which is
hilarious
and um and then you have some good like
kind of phrases or one-liners that hit
well i'll take it so ben a minus but
we'll try to get some hose water stuff
but
people are still com people tweet at me
and call me hose water i love it
uh all right we're out of here
[Music]
you